por eso tenemos datos muy, muy inciertos.
Entonces, ¿cómo podemos detectar y corregir estas inconsistencias?
¿Cómo podemos representar esa incertidumbre?
Es difícil. Algo que podemos hacer
es documentar cada paso del proceso,
no solo codificar la información histórica
sino también lo que llamamos la información meta-histórica,
cómo se construye el conocimiento histórico,
documentar cada paso.
Eso no garantizará la convergencia
hacia una única historia de Venecia,
pero probablemente podamos reconstruir
una historia potencial de Venecia totalmente documentada.
Tal vez no haya un solo mapa.
Quizá haya varios mapas.
El sistema debe permitir eso,
porque tenemos que enfrentar una nueva forma de incertidumbre,
algo nuevo para este tipo de gigantescas bases de datos.
Y ¿cómo deberíamos comunicar
esta nueva investigación a un público más amplio?
Una vez más, Venecia es extraordinaria para eso.
Con los millones de visitantes que recibe cada año
es uno de los mejores lugares
para tratar de inventar el museo del futuro.
Imaginen que en el eje horizontal ven el mapa reconstruido
de un año dado,
y en el vertical, ven el documento
usado para la reconstrucción,
pinturas, por ejemplo.
Imaginen un sistema inmersivo que permita
meterse, bucear y reconstruir la Venecia de un año dado,
una experiencia que podría compartirse en grupo.
O al contrario, imaginen que parten
de un documento, un manuscrito veneciano,
y muestran lo que se puede construir a partir de eso,
cómo se decodifica,
cómo puede recrearse el contexto de ese documento.
Esta es la imagen de una muestra
que actualmente se lleva a cabo en Ginebra
con ese tipo de sistema.
Para concluir, podemos decir que
la investigación en humanidades está a punto de experimentar
una evolución quizá similar
a lo ocurrido con las ciencias de la vida hace 30 años.
Es realmente una cuestión de escala.
Vemos proyectos que exceden
lo que puede hacer un simple equipo de investigación
y esto es realmente nuevo para las humanidades,
que muy a menudo tienen el hábito de trabajar
en pequeños grupos o solo con un par de investigadores.
Cuando uno visita el Archivio di Stato
siente que excede el trabajo de un solo equipo,
y que debe ser un esfuerzo conjunto y mancomunado.
Este cambio de paradigma requiere
fomentar una nueva generación
de "humanistas digitales"
que estén preparados para el cambio.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)